zdf heute live herzlich willkommen die
bilder aus dem ukrainischen botschaft
haben weltweit entsetzen ausgelöst und
die forderungen nach konsequenzen werden
immer lauter
das ist ein vorort von kiew am
donnerstag haben sich die russischen
truppen von dort zurückgezogen die
bilder danach zeigen zerstörungen
verwüstungen und dutzende leichen von
mehr als 400 toten zivilisten spricht
die ukrainische generalstaatsanwältin
russland weist die vorwürfe von sich
hier kriegsverbrechen begangen zu haben
außenminister lavrov nennt es einen
erfundenen angriff um russland zu
diskreditieren
das grün ist die ukraine präsident
seelands die der heute vor ort war so
weit irgend den russischen soldaten
genutzt
das ist unser thema heute wie immer ihre
und eure fragen in die kommentare oder
wenn er oder sie die app nutzt bitte an
die eingeblendete e mail adresse eine e
mail schicken an zdf heute.de
zdf.de
unsere korrespondentin katrin eigendorf
ist vor ort im moment in kiew sie war
heute den tag über in butter unterwegs
katrin kannst du uns schildern was du
dort gesehen hast
ja das war eine organisierte pressefahrt
des beraters des innenministers der
ukraine der hat journalisten aus allen
möglichen ländern der welt vor allem
europäer zusammengeholt wir sind in zwei
bussen nach butter gefahren auch an
einige andere orte und konnten uns da
einen eindruck davon machen was da
passiert ist die situation ist so dass
man inzwischen die leichen von den
straßen geholt hat aber ansonsten sieht
eigentlich alles noch so aus als wäre
die russische armee gerade dort
abgezogen wir sind streckenweise an
ausgebrannten
zivilfahrzeugen vorbeigekommen an
ausgebrannten panzern
überall zerstörte häuser im ort butscher
selber ist die hauptstraße übersät von
zerstörten autos von ausgebrannten
panzern
von hinterlassenschaften
russischer soldaten ganz klar erkennbar
die meisten leute haben den ort
verlassen
die wenigen die geblieben sind die waren
auch sehr schwer zu erreichen zu einem
gespräch präsident selensky ist selber
nach butter gekommen das war vorher
nicht angekündigt worden und man muss
sich vorstellen das ist natürlich ein
sehr sehr großes risiko für den
präsidenten nach botschaft zukommen weil
dieser ort kann natürlich nach wie vor
auch von russland aus der luft
angegriffen werden er ist ganz stark
abgeschirmt worden man hat im prinzip
auch die handy leitungen alle
unterbrochen damit er dort nicht
zuordnen ist und er hat mit journalisten
gesprochen und ich habe ihn selber als
sehr angefasst erlebt also
er hatte stellenweise sogar einen hauch
von tränen in den augen war mein
eindruck diese situation zu beschreiben
den journalisten noch mal klar zu machen
wie wichtig es ist dass zu zeigen dass
dort solche greueltaten passiert sind
das eigentlich kaum vorstellbar ist dass
frauen vor den augen ihrer kinder
vergewaltigt wurden dass familien
ermordet wurden wir sind dann nachdem
wir dort mit präsident selensky
zusammengetroffen sind und da auch ein
interview mit ihm machen konnten es war
natürlich eine sehr große gruppe von
journalisten war auch nicht so ganz
einfach jetzt da fragen zu stellen aber
wir hatten gelegenheit auch mit ihm ein
paar fragen zu stellen hat man uns dann
weiter gebracht in einem dorf
wo wir uns einen grab angeguckt haben
ich habe das selber als journalistin in
meiner gesamten laufbahn noch nicht
erlebt dass man journalisten so nah an
opfer heran führt es war eine familie
vier menschen die wirklich hingerichtet
wurden also ganz klare spuren einer
hinrichtung einer ermordung
der berater des
innenministers hat auch sehr emotional
dort an dieser stelle zu journalisten
gesprochen und gesagt die welt muss das
erfahren dass muss dokumentiert werden
und ich glaube im moment ist den
ukrainern schon klar dass der druck
wächst diese gräueltaten sind so
unvorstellbar das ist ganz ganz wichtig
ist hier sehr sehr sachlich und sehr
nüchtern nachzuweisen was hier
tatsächlich passiert ist wirklich die
einzelnen leichen eben auch noch einmal
zu untersuchen genau festzustellen was
mit den menschen passiert ist und
kartieren mir sogleich katrina wir
werden gleich drauf drauf kommen und
auch von dir normal erfahren was denn
vor ort an untersuchungen jetzt auch
stattfinden welche beweise gesichert
werden können aber ich würde gern mit
dir zusammen anschauen welchen bericht
du uns mitgebracht hat welche bilder du
heute gedreht hast mit welchen leuten du
heute in butter sprechen konnte ist
schauen wir uns gemeinsam an
auf der roxeler straße in butter sieht
es fast noch so aus als seien die
russischen soldaten gerade erst
abgezogen nur die leichen der menschen
die hier lagen haben sie inzwischen
geborgen es sind bilder die nur schwer
erträglich sind das innenministerium hat
journalistinnen aus aller welt
eingeladen das zu dokumentieren und
präsident sie lenski ist persönlich nach
rutscher gekommen es ist ihm anzumerken
wie nah es ihm geht wenn er schildert
wie hier frauen vergewaltigt familien
hingerichtet wurden das land müsse
kämpfen aber gleichzeitig verhandlungen
führen
ich bin überzeugt dass wir auf dem
territorium der ukraine frieden
erreichen die ukraine kann nicht im
krieg leben denn wir sind im europa des
21 jahrhunderts
in zwar verkehrs bussen die sonst in den
vorstädten fahren bringt das ukrainische
innenministerium
journalistinnen zu den orten aus denen
die russische armee vertrieben wurde
überall auf der straße ausgebrannte
autos von zivilisten zerstörte russische
panzer im dorf macht tisch in zeigt uns
der berater des innenministers einer
familie die nach seiner überzeugung von
russischen soldaten getötet wurde sieben
dieser abschaum hat eine ganze familie
gefoltert geprügelt und ermordet sie
werden dafür zur verantwortung gezogen
werden wir finden alle die diese
schreckliche tat begangen hat
präsident sie lenski bezeichnet butscher
als ein symbol für den völkermord
russlands an den ukrainern die welt soll
das sehen und gleichzeitig wollen die
ukraine genau dokumentieren vielleicht
wird über butscher eines tages vor einem
internationalen gerichtshof verhandelt
werden
[Musik]
der kathrin das ist jetzt natürlich auch
die große frage welche juristischen
konsequenzen können daraus gezogen
werden und da sehen wir auf der einen
seite sehr viele journalisten die ihre
arbeit machen weil sie berichten über
das was vor ort passiert ist
gleichzeitig müssen ja jetzt aber auch
die berichterstatter der menschenrechts
organisationen des internationalen
strafgerichtshofs vor ort ihre ihre
ermittlungen durchführen wie wie
hilfreich ist es da wenn viele
journalisten da vor ort sind
durchgeführt werden und möglicherweise
auch spuren verwischen
also ich kann nicht bestätigen dass
journalisten da spuren vor sich
verwischen denn es kommt ja
hauptsächlich darauf an jetzt die
leichen zu untersuchen was mit den
menschen passiert ist sie dort gestorben
sind und man hat uns journalisten
eigentlich in reserve grenzen zugang
gegeben zu nur einem ganz kleinen
ausschnitt dieses ortes zu bestimmten
stellen wir konnten dort zum beispiel
aus der ferne aufnahmen machen aber
nicht direkt nah dran ich habe das nur
erwähnt weil das schon sehr ungewöhnlich
ist dass man journalisten diesen zugang
gibt sehr wichtig für die ukraine ist
und ich glaube auch insgesamt für die
weltöffentlichkeit ist hier der
russischen propaganda einfach auch
fakten entgegenzusetzen
wie machen die das also zum beispiel
eine organisation human rights watch ist
hierbei der untersuchung dabei jeder hat
eine subjektive wahrnehmung das heißt
sie versuchen möglichst viele menschen
zu den vorgängen hier zu interviewen das
abzugleichen mit dem was sie an den
menschen auch feststellen können an
spuren von vermeintlicher folter von
vergewaltigung und sich aus diesem allen
ein bild zusammenzusetzen
aber was ich als journalistin sagen muss
ist ja sicherlich unsere aufgabe immer
alle perspektiven darzustellen aber das
was russland hier sagt dass es sich hier
um eine inszenierung handelt das ist
keine perspektive
das ist eine glatte und zynisch und
infame lüge denn so etwas kann man gar
nicht inszenieren wir haben das mit
unseren eigenen augen und ich habe das
mit meinen eigenen augen vor ort gesehen
was da passiert ist ich habe die
menschen da liegen sehen das waren zwar
nur noch wenige die dort geblieben sind
und wir haben sehen können wie auch die
leichen geborgen wurden von menschen die
ganz eindeutig gefoltert wurden das sind
bilder die können wir gar nicht im
fernsehen zeigen das ist unzumutbar
eigentlich für einen normalen zuschauer
ich habe es gesehen und es werden auch
die internationalen
untersuchung organisationen zu sehen
bekommen und ich denke ja die
aufarbeitung ist einfach wichtig um
irgendwann auch diese fakten zu haben
vielleicht um das ganze für einen
internationalen gerichtshof zu bringen
aber auch um der welt öffentlichkeit
klar zu machen was hier wirklich
passiert
damit ist auch die frage von einigen
userinnen und usern beantwortet oder die
behauptung die hier auch im chat immer
wieder auftauchte nicht hier in die
kommentare gucke da gibt es fragen wie
haltet ihr es für möglich dass die
ukraine so eine situation inszenieren
würde das hast du gerade sehr deutlich
gesagt dass es aus deiner sicht nicht
vorstellbar dankeschön kathrin und an
dieser stelle noch ein dank an seine
berichterstattung von einer userin
namens mary diehl 1 0 80 schreibt über
youtube hochachtung vor katrin eigendorf
danke schön dass du vor ort bist und
dass du dir ein eigenes bild gemacht
hast an dem die uns teilhaben lassen für
ihre teilhaben lassen dankeschön patrick
und katrin eigendorf hat es angesprochen
ganz wichtig sind die eindrücke von
augenzeugen von menschen die vor ort
sind und die gräuel miterlebt haben und
wir lassen noch mal zwei von ihnen zu
wort kommen
aber meinen mann anhand seiner schuhe
erkannt seiner hose sein gesicht war
entwürdigt ich bin zum roten kreuz
gegangen und habe gefragt was ich tun
soll
er wurde einen meter tief begraben
gerade so dass keine hunde fressen das
war's
ich habe gesehen wie die menschen hier
gejagt wurden die russischen soldaten
haben ihre gewehre gezogen und gesagt
sie werden uns töten
sie hielten grundlos autos an und
feuerten raketen auf irgendwas ab
louis nach
zugeschaltet ist wenzel michalski
direktor von euch human rights watch in
deutschland herr michalsky human rights
watch beobachtet seit jahrzehnten
kriegsverbrechen auf der ganzen welt die
bilder aus botschaft was was was macht
das mit ihnen was was ist dort passiert
das ist natürlich ganz furchtbar wir
müssen trotzdem einen analytischen
kühlen kopf behalten so herzlos das
vielleicht klingen mag um eben diese
verbrechen auch möglichst objektiv
darstellen zu können und beweise liefern
zu können wir machen das mit
wissenschaftlichen methoden natürlich in
der hoffnung irgendwann einmal die
verantwortlichen für diese gräueltaten
für diese unmenschlichen verbrechen zur
verantwortung zu ziehen wie genau gehen
die kollegen von ihnen die mutmasslich
jetzt schon vor ort sind oder vielleicht
bald vor ort sein werden vielleicht
können sie dazu auch was sagen wir gehen
die jetzt genau vor
ja wir sind vor ort ich meine ukraine
ist ein großes land das heißt wir sind
in den landesteilen den landesteilen wir
können unsere mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter nicht direkt an die front
schicken da lässt sich auch schlecht
lassen sich schlecht sachen analysieren
unter feuer aber wir sprechen mit den
menschen die dort gewohnt haben und
vielleicht geflüchtet sind wir sprechen
mit den menschen direkt wenn wir so über
telefon erreichen wir arbeiten seit
langer zeit in und an diesem land und
haben dort viele kontakte die
augenzeugenberichte und die berichte der
opfer
vergleichen wir mit aussagen im internet
zum beispiel social media oder den
chatrooms wir haben fotos die wir
analysieren und videoaufnahmen die wir
analysieren und davos nur sich
schnittstellen ergeben von den fakten
die berichtet werden das heißt da wo die
fakten ein match ergeben und gleich sind
da wissen wir ja da ist was wahres dran
und dann wissen wir auch dass wir hier
einen fall haben den wir veröffentlichen
können
haben jetzt gerade am wochenende einen
bericht veröffentlicht mit sieben fällen
knallharten fällen wir haben sehr viel
mehr fälle untersucht aber bei diesen
sind wir sicher dass sie auch wirklich
stimmen
welche rolle spielt denn die obduktion
der leichen und wie schwierig ist dass
das durchzuführen wenn diese menschen
einmal in massengräbern bestattet worden
sind und das ist ja genau das was man
jetzt tun muss man man muss die toten
bestatten aber gleichzeitig ist es auch
wichtig da durch spuren damit spuren zu
sichern mit denen man verbrechen
aufklären kann
genau also die orte wo das passiert sind
wo die verbrechen passiert sind sind ja
tatorte das heißt man muss sie
eigentlich sichern wie die polizei am
tatort wo ein mord oder eine
vergewaltigung geschehen ist dann auch
absichert und die nach spuren sucht und
die spuren dokumentiert insofern ist
auch die forensik das heißt die
leichenschau eine sehr wichtige arbeit
ich bin deswegen froh als ich gelesen
habe und dann york times dass die
gerichtsmediziner von butscher schon
angefangen hatten schon während der zeit
der besatzung unter großer gefahr die
leichen zu untersuchen und zu
dokumentieren dass mehrere dutzend haben
die das amt sowohl bei mehreren dutzend
geschafft
es lässt sich natürlich nicht vermeiden
jetzt dass die leichen in massengräbern
kommen aber diese massengräber müssen
geschützt werden dass sie dann aber
durch fachleute auch wieder ausgegraben
werden und
entsprechend untersucht werden wir haben
leider schon in anderen ländern wie zum
beispiel syrien gesehen dass
massengräber irgendwann die die leute
wurden exhumiert und die familie hat
natürlich großen wert darauf gelegt in
aller würde die menschen dann zu
begraben aber das bedeutet auch dass
dann bei einer weiteren extrem wertvolle
beweise verloren gehen und das wollen
unterhaltung wie das das wollen wir
verhindern und wir fordern und wünschen
uns sehr stark von der kleinen regierung
dass sie diese massengräber abschirmt
voran zugriff
jetzt machen sie genau den spagat auf in
dem ich mich gerade mit katrin eigendorf
gefunden habt denn auf der einen seite
haben wir gerade darüber gesprochen
müssen auch die journalisten ihren job
machen und berichten was vor ort
passiert ist wir haben gesehen es sind
viele journalisten da das ist ja auch
gut für die ukraine wiederum ist es
wichtig dass die welt diese bilder sieht
aber für ihre ermittler für ihre
mitarbeiter ist es wichtig dass diese
tatorte gesichert werden wie wird man
denn allen gleichzeitig gerecht
das kann man wahrscheinlich nicht und
deswegen
ist es nötig so viel wie möglich zu
sichern ich kann mir jetzt nicht
vorstellen dass die journalisten die
darum gehen beweise vernichten nur weise
da herumlaufen man sieht ja das ist ein
riesengroßes chaos wird sowieso ist es
ein chaos herrscht mit dem ganzen
krempel das dann noch überall steht es
ist halb wahnsinnig wichtig dass die
leichen geborgen werden ja dass man so
darauf aufpasst dass diese weise die man
an den leichen finden kann das heißt
einschusslöcher ein schusswinkel usw die
verletzungen dass das
nachvollziehbar wird und bleibt ist
bitter für sie nach allem was man lesen
kann kein einzelfall in wissen sie von
anderen fällen in welchen orten
recherchiert jungen rights watch gerade
noch
leider müssen wir davon ausgehen dass es
kein einzelfall ist wir haben mehrere
orte sowie butscher zb forssell 50
kilometer nordwestlich von kiew andere
ortschaften in der region von car kit
untersucht in der zeit vom 27
februar bis 14 marx und haben dort
ähnliche gräueltaten feststellen müssen
wir haben einen bericht aus einem
kleineren ort von einer mutter die sich
mit ihrer fünfjährigen tochter im keller
einer schule versteckt hat gemeinsam mit
anderen menschen in die schule
eingedrungen sind dann russische
soldaten haben die mutter nach oben
geschleppt in den oberen stockwerk haben
in ein klassenzimmer die mutter mehrmals
vergewaltigt und mit einem messer am
hals verletzt
wir haben erzählungen von einem ort in
dem eine mutter berichtet wie ihr mann
und ihr sohn gemeinsam mit vier anderen
von russischen soldaten abgeführt worden
sind sie haben gewehrschüsse gehört als
sie sich später traut nachzusehen haben
sie gesehen wie alle sechs männer tragen
wir haben bericht von einem aus einem
anderen ort da haben russische soldaten
nebelgranaten in einen keller geworfen
eine 60-jährige frau ist ring eine 41
jährige frau ist aus dem keller gegangen
mit einem 14 jährigen kind beide wurden
erschossen
diese gräueltaten
sehen wir und sie lassen wir sie deuten
darauf hin dass das was in butter
geschehen ist kein einmaliges verbrechen
ist leider außerdem sehen wir ja die
gezielte
massenvernichtung von zivilisten den
gezielten angriff auf wohnblöcke schon
seit anbeginn des krieges in takt von
johnny griffin mario pohl und anderen
städten auch das sind kriegsverbrechen
und wir sehen den einsatz von verbotener
streumunition und landenden land land
nehmen das sind alles schwerwiegende
kriegsverbrechen die sich auch von der
russischen regierung nicht mehr leugnen
lassen man muss davon ausgehen dass
diese kriegsverbrechen gezielt
eingesetzt werden als kriegstaktik
vielleicht um davon abzulenken dass das
militärische gerät der russen nicht so
gut ist da versuchen wir das mit terror
angst und schrecken zu kompensieren nun
ist am ende natürlich die frage wer
dafür wie und wo juristisch zur
verantwortung gezogen werden kann und
verschiedentlich wird bereits ermittelt
auch schon lange vor butscher denn wie
sie auch gerade aufgezählt haben das hat
auch schon vorher vorfälle gegeben die
untersucht werden müssen dazu zdf
rechtsexperte christoph schneider
ja der internationale strafgerichtshof
in den haag hat schon bereits anfang
märz ermittlungen aufgenommen
chefankläger kann hat internationale
ermittler in das kriegsgebiet geschickt
um beweise zu sichern und zeugen zu
hören natürlich hören die ermittler auch
ukrainische behörden doch man darf bei
aller empörung nicht vergessen dass die
ukraine auch kriegspartei ist sicher
werden aber die ermittler des
internationalen strafgerichtshofs wie
schon in der ukraine sind sich auch
jetzt die situation und butscher genau
anschauen und auch da beweise sichern
wichtig ist bei allen ermittlungen die
unparteilichkeit in kriegsverbrechen
sind sogenannte micro verbrechen das
heißt es gibt viele taten und viele
tatverdächtige
strafrechtlich muss das aber genau
konkretisiert werden müssen wer hat was
wann gemacht und das muss dann den
einzelnen konfliktparteien zugeordnet
werden gibt es einen konkreten
tatverdacht gegen eine bestimmte person
welche einheit gehört der soldat an wer
war befehlshaber darüber und so weiter
und diese befehlskette müsste sich dann
bis ganz hoch in den kreml verfolgen
lassen erst einmal geht es um
beweissicherung und ermittlung ehemann
am ende verantwortliche benennt das ziel
müsse sein dass nach ganz gründlichen
umfassenden ermittlungen internationale
haftbefehle stehen das wäre die
konkreteste strafmaßnahme des
internationalen strafgerichtshofs danach
käme dann die vollstreckung dieser
haftbefehle gegen einzelne
verantwortliche bis vielleicht auch in
den kreml doch bis dahin ist noch ein
weiter weg
tja herr michalsky welche hoffnung haben
sie dass das tatsächlich am ende
menschen möglicherweise wladimir putin
selbst für mutmassliche kriegsverbrechen
in der ukraine zur verantwortung gezogen
werden können
es ist natürlich schwer zu spekulieren
was da in diesem fall passiert aber
generell besteht die hoffnung natürlich
wir haben ja gesehen im ehemaligen
jugoslawien krieg dass solche
verantwortlichen wie karadzic oder
milosevic tatsächlich am ende vor
gericht landet wir haben gerade
in koblenz die verurteilung von zwei
folterknechten aus syrien erlebt sie
hier festgenommen worden sind und denen
hier in deutschland der prozess gemacht
wurde zur zeit steht in frankfurt ein
volker arzt vor gericht in celle beginnt
demnächst ein
gerichtsverfahren gegen einen gambier
der kriegsverbrechen beschuldigt wird
also von ganz unten bis ganz oben haben
wir schon gesehen dass menschen zur
rechenschaft gezogen werden und dann
auch zu langjährigen gefängnisstrafen
verurteilt werden das las das lässt
hoffen wie das jetzt in diesem konkreten
fall aussehen wird ich denke mal dass
die erfahrungen die wir haben und die
hoffnung die wir haben dazu beitragen
wird dass doch irgendwann wenigstens
einige sehr verantwortliche menschen zur
rechenschaft gezogen werden nun gibt es
einen bericht von human rights watch an
dem russische menschenrechtler selbst
beteiligt waren und nachgewiesen haben
dass russische soldaten sich in syrien
auch an kriegsverbrechen beteiligt haben
und es gibt viele experten die sagen es
war ein fehler auch die russische
beteiligung an kriegsverbrechen den
syrien und auch in tschetschenien nicht
völkerrechtlich zu ernten denn wäre das
passiert dann wäre das ein deutliches
signal gewesen dass solche taten
konsequenzen haben würden sie damit
gehen auf alle fälle die welt hat zu
lange zugeschaut an den verbrechen durch
die russischen verantwortlichen durch
die regierung durch die armee wir
erleben ja jetzt was wir schon gesehen
haben in tschetschenien in grosny wir
erleben jetzt was auch schon gesehen
haben in der leppe und in der umgebung
von damaskus im nord-irak totale
zerstörungen durch die russische armee
mit hilfe der assad-regierung aber
natürlich geplant und taktisch
vorbreiten durchgeführt durch russische
soldaten und wir haben trotzdem also die
welt hat trotzdem zwar nicht geschwiegen
aber nicht wird nicht die konsequenzen
daraus gezogen so dass putin
offensichtlich davon ausgegangen ist er
kann das jetzt auch in der ukraine
machen
sagt wenzel michalski der direktor von
jungen in deutschland vielen dank herr
mich als geht dass sie heute abend bei
uns in der sendung waren
danke auch
einen kriegsverbrecher hat der
amerikanische präsident joe biden
wladimir putin schon genannt jetzt hat
er diesen vorwurf wiederholt und fordert
ein internationales
kriegsverbrechertribunal gegen putin
putin ist ein kriegsverbrecher wir
müssen weitere informationen sammeln und
die ukraine mit den nötigen waffen
versorgen um weiter widerstand zu
leisten und wir brauchen die details
damit wir einen prozess wegen
kriegsverbrechen einleiten können der
typ ist brutal und was in butter
passiert ist ist verstörend und alle
haben es gesehen
joe biden und jetzt ist bei mir in der
sendung doktor volker weichsel er hat
politik wissenschaft und slawistik in
mannheim und pf studiert und ist
redakteur der zeitschrift osteuropa
hdr wechsel wird das erfolg haben wird
eines tages vladimir putin vor einem
internationalen
kriegsverbrechertribunal stehen
das kann ich selbstverständlich nicht
versprechen dass er persönlich vor
diesem tribunal stehen wird aber es
werden verantwortliche aus russland vor
einem solchen tribunal stehen und ein
solches tribunal hat ja auch eine
weitreichende symbolische bedeutung wir
haben ist ja vorhin schon gehört von dem
kollegen mit kalski von human rights
watch es geht auch um abschreckung und
es geht auch um aufarbeitung es ist auch
für die opfer von größter bedeutung dass
diese verbrechen
nachträglich aufgearbeitet werden das
müssen doch gerade wir in deutschland
wissen wir haben 70 jahre lang
nationalsozialistischer verbrechen
völkermord den holocaust aufgearbeitet
wir arbeiten das bis in die heutigen
tage noch auf bis hinunter in die
kleinste verästelung verantwortliche
werden gesucht und genau darum wird es
auch gehen das ist aber nur ein teil
dieser was wir gehört haben
langwierige
langfristige akribische präzise
juristische aufarbeitung ist äußerst
wichtig um jeden einzelnen fakt zu
bestätigen es gibt auch eine aber auch
eine politische seite und diese
politische seite hat nicht die zeit und
die beweise die vorliegen die reichen
aus es ist offensichtlich dass die kreml
propaganda legt es gibt die beweise
dafür dass diese verbrechen von der
russischen armee begangen würden gemacht
um zu fragen wie eine doppelte sorry
können wir genau an dem punkt bleiben
denn wenn ich hier in den er kurz
bleiben denn wenn ich hier in den chat
gucke dann sehe ich dass ganz viele
userinnen und user tatsächlich die frage
stellen können wir das glauben woher
können wir wissen dass es die russen
waren warum können es nicht so wie der
kreml ist behauptet kann es nicht ein
fake sein das behauptet der kreml warum
könnte es nicht eine false flag aktion
der ukraine gewesen sein was sagen sie
all denen die an dieses russische
narrativ glauben was sind ihre beweise
also es gibt zwei dimensionen die eine
dimension ist wir haben die historische
erfahrung damit wir haben die
historische erfahrung mit den russischen
verbrechen wir haben das gehört große
aleppo
wir haben die erfahrung mit der lüge das
ist die andere seite wir haben den
abschluss der mhh 17 im jahr 2014 und
die behauptung die bis heute
durchgehalten wird dass dieses flugzeug
von der ukrainischen seite abgeschossen
wird und es wurde mit den
verschiedensten methoden nachgewiesen
dass dass das eine lüge ist wir hatten
die lüge der krim annexion das ist ein
bisschen ein anderer fall aber putin
stellte sich hin und sagt wir wissen
überhaupt nicht wenn diese grünen
menschen sind und ein jahr später
stellte er sich mit preis bekleideten
sinne hat selbstverständlich wenn wir
das gewesen diese verbrechen die wir
jetzt gesehen haben da wird man sich
natürlich nicht ein der später stolz
hinstellen und behaupten das waren ja
doch wir gewesen kommt die dritte seite
und das sind die konkreten beweise in
diesem fall hatten die berichte und die
bilder ich habe sie gesehen die nicht
erst jetzt wo das ganze an die
öffentlichkeit geht aus dem großraum
kiel kamen wir hatten vereinzelt von
russischer seite und von ukrainischer
seite der örtlichen bevölkerung
augenzeugen berichte und bilder die aus
der zeit stammt in den gesamten drei
wochen in denen die besatzung durch die
russischen soldaten stattfand also das
ist einfach nicht so dass das alles erst
jetzt am vierten april oder am dritten
april nach dem abzug der russischen
armee überhaupt erst gekommen das sind
jetzt nur die großen bilder und das
nächste ist ganz konkret
das kann man auch diesen bildern
aussehen ist der verwesungszustand der
leichen ich muss es so sagen die leichen
die dort liegen die sind nicht am
zweiten april dorthin gelegt worden dass
bestehen bestätigen auch verschiedene
menschen die sich mit der forensik
auskennen die bilder gesehen haben und
menschen vor ort und augenzeugen sind in
den autos schon vor drei wochen
erschossen worden auf der flucht aus den
städten und es ist ja auch nicht nur
besser sondern es sind viele andere
kleine dörfer und städte aus diesem
gesamten großraum kiew wo die russische
armee gestanden hat
butter ist ein name der wichtig ist soll
man sich an einem namen festhält und der
das kennen wir aus bosnien herzegowina
aus dem jugoslawienkrieg wo im gesamten
land völkermord und genozid begangen
wurde und der größte und deswegen ist es
der name in dem wir uns ändern ist
sabrina und so werden wir auch besser
als name im gedächtnis behalten und
dürfen dabei aber nie vergessen dass es
überall dort stattgefunden hat wo die
russische armee war und wir wissen noch
gar nicht was in den gegenden ist wo sie
heute noch steht also im süden vor allem
in mini kabul in person
und anderen städten an indem rufe gebiet
am asowschen meer okay ein kommentar
eines users das sind viele und viele 000
ich glaube es heißt 00
auf youtube schreibt wir müssen einen
kühlen kopf bewahren wir müssen die
konsequenzen durch planen und dann erst
handeln auch bei aller verständlichen
bestürzen das ist auch das was wenzel
michalski gerade sagte wir müssen jetzt
vor allem auch untersuchen was vor ort
tatsächlich passiert ist
ein user greift auch das auf was sie
gerade schon gesagt haben die lügen die
wir aus dem russischen regime in der
vergangenheit gesehen haben rib dort 157
schreibt auch über youtube russland hat
schon bei emh 19 also wir wissen m h 17
und dem einmarsch der krim gelogen warum
sollten sie jetzt plötzlich die wahrheit
sagen das ist das was sie was sie auch
gerade gesagt haben
jetzt fragt hier auch über youtube
cornelius zenker was sind denn
realistische diplomatische szenarien
damit russland aus der nummer wieder
rauskommt und die frage ist natürlich
auch gibt es nach dieser nach den
bildern die wir jetzt aus butter gesehen
haben überhaupt eine diplomatische
lösung
es hat auch davor bereits keine
diplomatische lösung gegeben das ist
leider leider eine eine illusion man
muss sich das ganz klar machen auch noch
mal in zusammenhang mit
dusche was wir dort sehen ist das
konkrete morden und schlachten und
vernichten und plündern durch einzelne
soldaten die durch den krieg und durch
die art und weise wie diese armee
organisiert ist denn das ist keine armee
in der bürger in uniform sind sondern es
ist eine verrohte armee diese selber
diese soldaten leiden selber unter der
gewalt ihrer offiziere sie werden
gefunden sie werden wenn sie als
rekruten in die armee kommen
vergewaltigt es gibt ein unglaubliches
inneres gewalt in dieser armee und das
kommt dann in dieser kriegssituation wo
sie ja auch genehmigt wurden durch die
ukrainische abwehr zum ausbruch das ist
die eine seite die andere seite ist dass
das ganze jahr ideologisch vorbereitet
und gedeckt ist von höchster seite wir
haben bei der kriegserklärung des
russischen präsidenten im 24 februar
gehört es ging um die den artifiziellen
der ukraine und wir haben heute genau am
heutigen tag in einem text der auf der
staatlichen nachrichtenagentur ria
nowosti erschienen ist erklärt bekommen
noch einmal in aller deutlichkeit was
das bedeutet am anfang schien es so als
sei die nazi fi zierung nur die
ukrainische führung umzubringen oder zu
verschleppen und und in moskau vor einer
schau gericht zu stellen heute wird
offen erklärt bei der staatlichen
nachrichtenagentur dass große teile der
ukrainischen bevölkerung
massiv ii ziert sein sie seien also
nazis es wird konkret dazu aufgerufen
alle menschen die sich als ukraine
empfinden und sagen wir sind ukraine und
sich verteidigen umzubringen es ist ein
aufruf zur ethnischen säuberung das ist
die offizielle ideologie in moskau und
das ist die kehrseite die eben nicht die
kehrseite sondern die spiegel seite der
gleichen hintze die zu dieser
erhöhung der soldaten in deren armee
dazu gehört und da muss man sich fragen
und welche diplomatische lösung kann
esta gehen und da muss man alles klar
sehen wir haben rein militärisch gesehen
rein militärisch
einen gewissen rückzug und eine
verringerung der russischen
angriffspläne warum haben wir diese
verringerung gesehen wie haben sie
deswegen gesehen weil die russische
armee gescheitert ist
ausschließlich die stärke der
ukrainischen armee die waffen diese
geliefert bekommen hatten die waffen die
sie hatten das training das sie bekommen
hatten ausschließlich
dass diese militärische fähigkeit hat
kiew davor bewahrt zu einem großen
bruder zu werden das muss man einfach so
deutlich erkennen und das bedeutet dass
diplomatie nur in dem
sinne erfolg haben kann wenn die ukraine
sich militärisch mit unserer
unterstützung
durch waffen und durch im bios
durchsetzt dann wird russland auch in
der lage sein das mit einer neuen ära
tief einer neuen erzählung in
irgendeiner weise wieder einzufangen so
wie wir jetzt gesehen haben okay das war
ja nie geplant jetzt kommt plan zwei die
operation läuft planmäßig die propaganda
ist in der lage den niederlage als
erfolg zu verkaufen da das müssen wir
diese niederlage versuchen bei zu führen
dann lassen sie uns auch in seiner
niederlage versuchen herbeizuführen ja
dann lassen sie uns noch einmal über das
sprechen wie die kommunikation jetzt
aktuell zur botschafter läuft von
russischer seite denn das ist ja auch
teil dessen was sie gerade gesagt haben
wenn wir uns anschauen
außenminister lavrov spricht von einem
erfundenen angriff die sprecherin des
russischen außenministeriums maria sakar
opfer sagt es seien bestellte bilder von
den vereinigten staaten und der nato und
das russische verteidigungsministerium
lässt über social media verbreiten die
leichen hätten sich bewegt das schreibt
übrigens auch ein user namens sehr
geheim über youtube zitat alles lüge
guckt euch das genau an manche leichen
bewegen sich komisch oder inzwischen ist
auch klar dass das eine lüge ist denn es
ist klar woher diese bewegungen kommen
es gibt geschäfte gruppen die sich damit
beschäftigt haben und festgestellt haben
dass die leichen sich natürlich nicht
bewegen sondern dass die bewegungen
durch regentropfen auf der
windschutzscheibe eines autos zum
beispiel hervorgerufen wurden wie geht
man denn mit dieser desinformation um
man muss sich einfach klarmachen dass
sie verschiedene ursachen hat also was
die höchsten verantwortlichen betrifft
das ist doch klar das ist sich jetzt
nicht hinstellen und sagen oh
entschuldigung das war ein versehen ja
also es ist ja voraussehbar wie die
reaktion da ist und wenn man sich das
klar macht und die fakten dagegen hält
glaube dann kann man damit einfach sehr
gut umgehen das haben wir jetzt auch in
den letzten 30 minuten sehr gut gesagt
was die einzelnen menschen betrifft und
auch ihren user der jetzt das so
kommentierte da würde ich jetzt gar
nicht unbedingt
urteilen denn ich kenne die einzelne
menschen ja nicht aber mal ganz ganz
menschlich gesehen der schock ist ja
auch so groß dass man etwas nicht
wahrhaben möchte und versucht
erklärungen zu finden für etwas was man
einfach nicht sehen will
und natürlich wäre es schön wenn das
alles die stattgefunden hätte und
ich glaube da kann jeder für sich selber
was ich einfach auch noch mal klar
machen und zurück gehen an die anfänge
worin wurzeln denn dieser eigene glaube
dass man etwas nicht wahrhaben möchte
hat man situationen erlebt in denen man
nachhinein dem stimm heimlich eigentlich
zugegeben hat man hat doch geirrt und
wenn man dass man versucht und dann noch
mal die fakten dagegen hält dann halte
ich es auch wirklich für die einzelnen
menschen die nichts wissen die keine
politische verantwortung tragen sondern
die hier im grunde
zuschauen aber ihr weltbild
aufrechterhalten möchten für die halte
ich es dann tatsächlich möglich noch mal
in sich zu gehen
nun ist die eine frage welche
juristischen folgen das hat das daran
wird gearbeitet haben wir gerade gesehen
die andere frage ist welche mittelbaren
oder unmittelbaren sanktionen das nach
sich zieht da sehen wir heute kommt ein
bisschen bewegung rein italien hat
angekündigt ähnlich abhängig von
russischem gas und öl wie deutschland
das es sich neuen sanktionen auch auf
dem energiesektor nicht in den weg
stellen wolle und immanuel makro der
gerade als französischer präsident den
eu-ratsvorsitz hat sagt neue sanktionen
müssten sich gegen kohle und öl richten
da ist das wort gas explizit ausgenommen
ist das ein szenario dass sie
vorstellbar für vorstellbar halten ein
energie embargo gegen russland als
nächster schritt der aber das gas nicht
mit beinhaltet
also ich halte das für absolut richtig
und wichtig und insbesondere das öl denn
die größten einnahmen russlands mit
denen sich das regime finanziert und die
stabilität momentan aufrechterhält wir
kommen nicht aus dem gas sondern die
kommen aus dem öl das ist das wichtigste
und gleichzeitig ist es so dass die
abhängigkeit von öl bei uns insofern die
ringe ist als das öl auf den weltmärkten
schneller zu besorgen ist gleichzeitig
man muss sehen wenn wir für teures geld
öl kaufen dann hat das folgen weltweit
trotzdem halte ich hier die substitution
also den ersatz von öl auf unserer seite
für leichter als bei gas
selbstverständlich müssen wir damit
rechnen wenn wir diese
maßnahmen ergreifen und ich halte es für
unbedingt wichtig und richtig
insbesondere um einfach auch mal vor
vor die ereignisse zu kommen es geht
nicht um die frage dass wir jetzt wieder
auf diese bilder reagieren müssen denn
wenn man
bereits vor zwei wochen oder vor drei
wochen den schritt gegangen wäre dann
hätte man es vielleicht nicht verhindern
vielleicht nicht verhindern können aber
man hätte es wenigstens versucht gehabt
und jetzt ist es wieder nur eine
reaktion wichtig ist bei der frage öl
oder gas
selbstverständlich muss man damit
rechnen dass russland als reaktion auf
ein ölembargo
umgekehrt obwohl es sich damit selbst
noch mehr ins fleisch schneidet dann
umgekehrt ein gasexport embargo verhängt
das szenario das man nicht ausschließen
kann dass muss man vor augen haben und
ich würde sagen das hat das
wirtschaftsministerium auch vor augen
momentan ist aber die lage so dass
russland mit der fokussierung auf das
gas tatsächlich erfolgreich versucht von
dem eigentlich schmerzhaften öl
abzulenken also diese ganze sache mit
der
gas darf nur noch in rubel bezahlt
werden hat sehr viele dimensionen
die eine dimension ist dies dazu war die
sensationen zu unterlaufen der andere
war wieder druck auszuüben aber eine
funktion hat es für meine begriffe auch
gab nämlich in diskussion von dem öl
wegzulenken das ist deswegen richtig und
das muss kommen und es wird kommen und
es ist besser wenn es mal endlich als
eigene politische außenpolitische aktion
kommt und nicht nur wieder in
erschrockene reaktion auf bilder sagt
der politikwissenschaftler dr volker
wechsel vielen dank dass sie bei uns im
studio und in der sendung waren vielen
dank und ich möchte die sendung hier
nicht beenden ohne noch eine antwort an
einen zuschauer mit auf den weg zu geben
cornelius zenker schreibt uns über
youtube zdf heute nachrichten gibt es
eine dritte quelle wo sich
unentschlossene leute mit material
informieren können was weniger für das
allgemein eine fernsehen geeignet ist
aber eindeutiger dokumentiert daraus
lese ich dass es noch ein großes
informationsbedürfnis gibt sich
unabhängig zu informieren und verweise
auf die kollegen von zdf heute wo sie
alle wichtigen informationen noch mal
finden zum nachlesen und wo sie auch die
erkenntnisse unseres fact checking teams
nachlesen können und sich dort selbst
ein bild machen können vielen dank dass
sie heute mit dabei waren danke fürs
kommentieren und fragen stellen bis zum
nächsten mal schießt